the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu hi Pablo good to be back
nice having you here so we wanted to
talk about um a number of like
high-level post morning me things for
how the class went so we've got some
high-level like things we wanted to talk
about want to talk about the
collaboration between the MIT and the
Red Cross Red Crescent grouping and your
folks how student preparedness went I've
been in particular comparing those teams
that got a lot of support like client
support on like snap of course but also
some of the other teams got a little bit
more and then the unsupported teams
which aren't exactly unsupported but
they got less so bless so that's a large
largely the heatwave team I think was
the the main one that we want to talk
about their so collaboration um what do
you all thought think about how we
talked to each other how we we met with
each other things like that well um I
like the way how we started the
beginning of the semester right you know
we had the talk we had some skype issues
but I think the idea of kicking off the
entire class with with the initial
presentation of this is what your final
projects going to become take us a while
to get there but you come into class
understanding this is what it's going to
be and Pablo being person to sort of to
sort of describe white is going to be
important I think said a lot of
expectations well so I think later on
when we actually got to that that
project the degree to which each team
actually could have been supported I
actually became more of an issue you
know the teams that you could directly
talk with and you you know what you were
going to be the primary user of the game
you know clearly benefited but because
but you were there right from the
beginning well these are the teams that
may
did receive support or some of them
didn't receive support but weren't
talking with people who have been dead
right from the start you know I think
felt my may have felt a little bit more
disconnected from from kind of the main
thrust of the class at least when I got
to that final final assignment so
something I'd like to think about for
future classes is the extent to which if
we're going to repeat this format where
the primary client comes in right at the
beginning to set the tone for the entire
class how do we represent more more of
the variety of different things that you
can do right at the beginning so that
when students think about what they're
going to be doing throughout the entire
semester they are actually keeping the
full scope of the project in mind not
dodge as the one example the
multi-purpose entertainment first day of
class and we also may want to have
something like an engagement meter
because I wasn't aware of the fact that
some teams were feeling disengaged I
would show up some people have questions
some other have less questions and from
my perspective those who have questions
I spent time and it was about the same
you know chronometric time per group I
could see that some were more lost but I
wasn't aware that what was nearly was
more fire in the belly so if we could
write at the when we asked the students
to do their post mortems they were
really clear about how this invented big
motivation and interest had been a big
problem for them but they never
mentioned it to us during check-in
meetings when we were doing playtesting
when we were working with them so that's
the sort of thing that we need to part
one thing to do is probably then to warn
them about that that these are hard
topics and they can become boring topics
very quickly um and they need to step up
and let us know when they think they're
they're facing a brick wall yeah yeah i
think the clothes were there like the
like there were if we had if we had
means and a way to remind ourselves to
like a checklist or something simple
like that just to say like are you
engaged what's your motivation and again
that's assuming that we even
want that to be our job I think for
anything client-based it has to be her
probably our job I think that I think
that when we're asking them to work on
projects where they have relatively
little control over the topic I think we
actually do need to because I think part
of it was I don't think the teens knew
how much freedom they had to deviate
from the topic they had chosen in the
specific they thought they had chosen
this thing and now they were stuck with
it even though one team was like we
chose a topic that just wasn't deep
enough there wasn't enough there um and
if they'd come and talk to us we could
have given them the freedom to go
changing your topic or how can we be in
how can we go deeper in it right but but
we were not sufficiently well but but
that's why rapport with someone who
knows a lot about the domain can can can
help and if they don't feel like they
have that rapport or someone who de can
readily contact for a to ask even
seemingly silly questions you know then
we're not going to be able to get them
to actually ask the important questions
because sometimes they can tell they
can't necessarily tell what what looks
like flagging motivation on the part of
the team or what just seems like end of
semester pressures on the students right
but you don't know they don't know they
haven't been working on enough projects
to be able to tell the difference and so
we do need to help them through that I
think students I mean the students and
one of the things you may want to
consider is we know that both in the
real life in the future in their future
as well as in future courses there will
be limited ability of those who are
experts to interact with the game design
team the game design team you took the
effort and I thought it was very well
balanced to have some who know
programming some who no narrative some
who know user interface and so on they
will by default not have expertise on
heat waves or cholera or etc or climate
science they cannot assume that all they
need to know including the appetite for
engagement will be only in the client
MIT is a bubbling powerhouse of engaging
stuff and if they could as part of what
they are told they will have to do in
the future and what they have
during this course to reach out to
engaging people fellow students junior
faculty or whoever may give them some
time to just go and say what is exciting
about this what are the cutting-edge
areas what are the institutional
challenges so that they you also have to
fuel their own appetite I having an
assignment or having part of that final
project being like here's the research
component that we expect you to do and
we done we didn't like put another line
on over it we did when it was in trouble
like for saving Gora Gora they were and
they were in big trouble we told him a
number he told him we told him I think
it'd be surprised with what they came up
with Mike because they they actually I
think they took the baton and went with
it the other cholera team did not and
they were given the same almost the
exact same feedback but the thing I
think there is a huge social barrier
between the undergraduates and the rest
of the Institute you know you would know
the Nobel laureates and even the
postdocs here that's a lot of social
pressure keeping students away from it
from that kind of interaction yea ye all
right all these things do exist here at
MIT but you know some of this reinforced
by professors themselves right there no
professors will keep the doors closed
when you're in the office I think like
like like that and so I do think some
sort of like we have to give you the
license and sometimes that's pointing
them to specific people giving them
resources like here's a list one of
these might pan out for you the others
might not and that's okay just do it you
can kind of prime them for it it's hard
to be a teenager in this yeah into space
yeah so yes actually since we're talking
about the student preparedness in that
research like you know what we saw
between the Weber what we consider the
supported teams vs the unsupported team
which may or may not be fair could be
the motivating teams vs the unmotivated
teams I'd snap in particular really
really well supported they got a lot of
they actually reached out to to you all
for for help with the game you actually
even did testing for them and that was
actually coming from from you and Jan oh
yeah because you were running workshops
how did those how did those workshops
run with like how to
you interact with the team so first of
all I think it's important to
distinguish and not only what you are
calling supportive versus and supportive
but also snap versus everything else
because nap was a game concept that
pre-existed the course that needed
refinement and digital interface so from
that perspective it's not surprising
that they had something clearly find
that they could run faster deeper and
the group was a group that engaged and
went deep and went fast the interactions
we have did when they also very
importantly we have events by that we
could use the product so it was much
easier to give feedback saying when we
do this we expect people that will get
bored why don't we try this other thing
it's milestones which we give them
milestones but there there is no weight
behind them these ones have an actual
like if it doesn't work by then
someone's going to have egg on your face
right and from that perspective I mean
we know this but we can try to do more
of giving students a more proportion of
work that we know we the client know
that we have milestones and that is
limited by how much the real word gives
us five stars / but we can try that I do
not feel comfortable with the label
supportive versus unsupported because it
sounds like some got time and support
and some others didn't I think it's it's
more about the form of the relationship
and how the time was used or the
opportunity to use that time was used
because you know this I have no doubt
and you supported the team when you knew
support was needed and as far as i know
the same was true on on our part I think
it's more about having sensors about
when support is needed that is not being
delivered I think what we're like when
we're talking about them in this way i'm
i'm using it based on how they describe
their own relationship and their own
experience so that the teams who we're
calling unsupported were the ones who in
their post mortems called out and said
we didn't feel like we got client
support it they got the same amount it
was a different way different quality
different quantity the way to print is
the same support was there for them they
I don't think a one other way to put it
is they didn't know how to reach out and
get it they did not they didn't use the
resources that were they
because at some level we weren't pushing
them at them and a lot of MIT courses
tend to encourage students to solve all
the problems themselves they don't want
them reaching out they want them you'll
figure this out and so it may come as
more of a second we may not come to his
first nature to go hey we need to go and
reach out some more help and grab this
and so that's actually the same thing so
we start with a snap team as we wanted
like the the feedback they were getting
from us was look at your front end look
at your UI we wanted to see a lot of
changes on the UI because they were
working on these milestones they were
really worried about the back end so
they're doing a lot of work on the back
end so there was a we were there were
two different they were getting two
different messages and they chose client
message rather than instructor message
right totally okay and totally viable um
we didn't like we took that into account
but that I think the main issues we had
with them is when they got our message
it was they heard it early on they
didn't react to it was too late have
they done a little bit extra in the
beginning so one thing I think we need
to think about with the class is
thinking about like how are we how are
we helping them understand how to
prioritize feedback right like what's
more important could be because well
here's something that's actually going
to use Duke also be well here's a lesson
we want to make sure they get and I
think they got the lesson they just got
it in a harder way sometimes they get a
lesson at a point of time that they
can't actually execute on it but you
know hopefully they can do it for the
next project after the class something I
want to suggest I actually because we've
been talking about how it's been
difficult for us to figure out what's
going on inside the team's you know we
can sort of see the games and that
testing but there's sort of Team
Dynamics they were no we don't find out
about that until near the end of the
class and something that we used to do
outside of this class but in our
research work was to get all of the
scrum masters together on a regular
basis to just do a sort of exchange of
information with each other right they
don't even have to be necessary
reporting to us although we can moderate
those sessions it's more about
then sharing their experiences with each
other and then we make it more obvious
that say there are resources out there
that some teams are taking advantage of
and some teams aren't and maybe they can
you know of course we can t use also
those situations for teaching but also
for sort of like teaching each other
yeah creating some group support yeah
yeah we talked about that before this
this semester started but we couldn't
figure out a way to good to figure out a
way to do that fairly like I already
feel producers bear the brunt of the
work in the class like there are the
ones we see all the time we don't see
that the students working on programming
or design as much design a little bit
more but programming we just almost
never see and we let the teams use the
producers as their face so giving all
the presentations giving all the reports
answering questions when we asked
questions in class um I think about how
we how we convince the teams to share
out that work a little bit more evenly
but perhaps maybe we can reduce the
extent that we require these these
producers to do presentations in class
and replace that with you know these
sort of more clothes clothes off
sessions where they don't feel like they
have to be on stage and put on the best
place for the team they can actually
just talk about this is the problem I'm
having with my team yeah so one thing I
also wanted to make sure we talk about
is what did what was it like for you
like how much of art of your time did we
demand like was it a lot compared to
other projects was it a little bit like
was it about moderate I want to start by
saying one of the things that I really
appreciate it was the time we spent both
face-to-face and emailing and so on
before the beginning of the course to
have understanding of what you and your
students can offer what we need and can
offer and to manage expectations as you
said I think that was very well done and
it's not always the case so we with with
students and professors and red cross in
general within and beyond game so thank
you that was really appreciated I think
that the the amount of time that I
personally have to give was about as
much as I anticipated and about as much
as I think he's
honorable to expect for the future we
did have shawano in particular and a few
other members of the team of the red
cross team who were available to give a
hand and I think we need to improve
because I I do make it very clear that I
couldn't get no five emails per day
asking questions but to have some kind
of ability for the rec contact when
either engagement levels are too low or
mega confusion levels are too high or or
sense of purpose is diluted and so on so
to refine that I think it would be
better to think of times when there can
be no slots of decided interaction
between each team and someone from the
client organization that doesn't have to
be during class so you because I always
we interfere with your plan well you
gave us one opportunity I thought it was
very useful but a little bit late in the
in the development process and also very
crammed by the time we said okay this is
the kind of thing you can do there was
no time for them to think reflect okay
we can do a or b or c show those to us
and then as providing figure so even if
it were one more chance via skype but
scheduled planned and if and and you
know it is in the nature of our work to
have to travel and it is in the nature
of our work that travel timing changes
outside of our control so there is a
default date anything has to be changed
it is changed but to know that there's
going to be an instance of feedback that
may be too little too late still but to
anticipate that um yeah part of that is
the students we don't always know the
students schedules right so it could
possibly be planned in the beginning of
the semester but planning it before this
muster be really difficult unless we
just say this is this is the time that
you're going to have if you don't take
advantage of it you don't get it right I
gonna be you know it has to be we
propose it's this week this is a default
time slot if not that time slot agree on
a different time slot yeah and then it's
up to this to you so you're actually
saying you kind of would have talked a
little bit more I if if the problem was
lack of engagement or perception of lack
of some totes really that planning and
scheduling as long as that's in place
then the time is
because it's been planned okay and also
I think it will have been nice for them
to have access to say someone from the
Ghana team to look at the color someone
from the heatwave team in Buenos Aires
do you know at least to get a flavor
there is another human being there that
eventually can use their game and I
didn't do enough to help them envision
the user either the Red Cross user or
the community level or policy or
government user right I think I think I
think we need to stay that strongly that
it's it's it's not just the information
that you're providing is the fact that
there is a real person who can really
benefit from the work that you're doing
is much more powerful than some sort of
abstracted audience tix we have we
played provided plenty of documentation
plenty of but that's that's not the same
as a human that's not the emotional
drive that they're going to get oh
someone's counting on me doing good work
so maybe it might just be our something
for us to talk to the terrace cope folks
to see how they do that well being
specifically get people and that that
who can commit on regular meetings and
the idea is my understanding is that is
for the domain knowledge prime primarily
but you get that site benefit of here's
a real human being who's excited about
this problem or what may be really
concerned about this problem and that
that that can be you know and that can
influence the Malaysian of a team and
also I don't know to what extent we can
keep cramming what students have to do I
know they already have to do way too
much but to look at how that kind of
field is currently being communicative
in the game universe and outside of that
so powerpoints or documents there across
the board generally boring and
unsuccessful even if they have the right
content so for them to get a sense that
if someone really needs to create
awareness on that topic and this is the
best they have in what exists in the
real world how about you know trying to
give something that makes people want to
do more through their name I I think I
think saying this is how low the bar is
can we get it slightly better it's less
motivating than saying what's the best
you can do
and I yeah I but it's also choosing
something that's going to get used like
why go in a direction that's not going
to like that they're just like this is
the if this is what those people are
thinking about if you give them
something completely not like that at
all they're probably not going to know
what to do with it very great but I mean
I i can imagine things like evaluating
current methods of teaching about a
certain concept can be part of that
research process that we were talking
about is understanding the problem cool
cool all right so I think it's got time
to let you go but thanks so much for
coming in we thank you huge gratitude